good evening if you are 65 and older and
you have not yet received the vaccine
state health leaders are encouraging you
to get it asap
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise valdez good evening i'm brian
loftis if you are concerned about
getting an appointment don't be there's
actually plenty of appointments
available throughout the valley and wait
times are extremely low
joel mohler is at one of those vaccine
clinic locations the las vegas
convention center
joe according to the state we must reach
a certain percentage of our older
population
in order to add another group correct
well that's right roughly 63 percent of
people over the age of 65
have received the vaccine state health
officials want to see that at 70 percent
now they're hoping with a dancing jensen
vaccine that is now available that will
encourage more people to get their shot
it was easy it was very easy the
vaccination process is getting easier
for people
i got my second shot and it's the first
day i'm ready for my second shot
it was very easy to get the right day
weeks ago people were waiting hours and
some had a difficult time making
appointments online
checked in and then went straight to the
vaccine i didn't wait more than 10
minutes
frank bellotti says he called wednesday
morning and was in
same day she had plenty of appointments
available today
tomorrow i previously checked with my
employer they had them there's 1500 up
in north las vegas
state health officials say they are
working on ways to encourage more people
to make appointments as many times are
not being reserved
they are urging more people over the age
of 65 to get the vaccine
the goal is to have at least 70 percent
of that age group vaccinated before
moving on to the next group
don't hesitate to sign up really not
that hard the single dose jansen vaccine
is now being offered baloti was able to
choose which vaccine he wanted at the
convention center
because he was there for his first shot
you had the choice when you walked in
they had the jansen or
pfizer depending on which ones you chose
what lane you took
now below there did end up actually
choosing the pfizer vaccine the jansen
vaccine is available at cashman center
and here at the las vegas convention
center
this week in addition to the moderna and
pfizer vaccines
now according to a popular facebook page
for vaccines people are also reporting
that you can also
find the jansen vaccine at grocery
stores such as vaughn's and albertsons
reporting live at the convention center
joe muller 8 news now